Things that are a cause for a
person's heart to become open
to the Quran and Sunnah, right?
This is what we started with.
and the first thing that he
mentioned was and so we took
about four sessions speaking
only about that subject of
Tohit. Honestly, I took it as
an opportunity. We learned
about the types of Tahid. We
learned about the types of
Shirk. We learned about the
types of hypocrisy. We learned
about the types of
prohibitions. And we learned
how all of this plays in to a
person's journey to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. You guys
remember all of that? We went
through that for a few weeks.
and now, we are going to
continue the issues that cause
a person's heart to become
open. Now, here's the issue
for you to become open to the
Quran in Sunnah have to become
open to the Quran in Sunnah. Do
you understand? Very strange
concept at first, okay? So,
let's go back to the very
beginning. To the very
beginning of the Quran. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said that
the Quran is a guidance for
who?
It is a guidance for the people
who revere and fear and obey
Allah. But isn't the Quran the
source of reverence and of
Allah?
Al Allah. Quran. Quran.
[Silence]
from a person's heart being
open to the Quran in Sunnah. Do
you understand? It is a
circular thing. It's a cycle.
Okay? Let's go back to the
beginning of the Quran. Allah
says that the Quran is a
guidance for the people of
Taqwa. The people of the people
who obey Allah, right? So, the
Quran is a guidance for the
people who obey Allah. But
isn't the Quran? The source of
obedience to Allah? What's the
answer? Yes, that's that's
where we learn how to obey
Allah. So, how are you obedient
to Allah to be able to learn
the Quran to become obedient to
Allah. Where does it first
start? It first starts with any
little thing of good that you
know Even as a non Muslim.
Let's say a person who is not
Muslim. This verse was revealed
to non Muslims. I mean it was
revealed to the prophet
speaking to non Muslims,
correct? He said, this is the
Quran, a great Quran, a
recitation. It is a guidance
for those who are people who
obey and revere Allah. These
were people who worshiped idols
But they had certain things
that they are sure of are from
Allah. what? telling
the truth. For instance.
Correct? Being truthful. Being
brave. Being generous. These
are parts of the truth that
come in all of the religions of
the prophets and messengers.
Correct? So if a knows that
truth and practices it, Allah
will guarantee to guide him to
another truth. And this process
of doing doing good and then
being guided to another good,
and then doing that good and
being guided to a greater good,
and then doing that good, and
being guided to a greater good.
It's a, it's a process, it's a,
it's a cycle that a person gets
in. And that cycle guides you
to Allah Just the
opposite. If a person this is
wrong and they do it, it will
lead them to what? Their heart
becoming more hard. The harder
their heart becomes, the more
evil they do. The more evil
they do, the more hard their
heart becomes. The more hard
their heart becomes, the more
evil they do. Until a person's
way is clear. Either to
paradise or hellfire. We
understand this process. I want
to summarize all of this and
summarize this concept in a
narration reported by on the
authority of Ennis.
And
[Silence]
There's an aeration collected
by Imam Ahmed. In which said
the prophet said to a man once,
become Muslim, enter into
Islam. The man's response, he
said, feel I don't want to
I feel my soul, my heart,
it's something I don't wanna do
So, the prophet said, become
Muslim in spite of yourself.
Right? Even if you don't want
to. What do we understand from
this hadith? This is an
incredibly eye opening
narration. What do we
understand from this narration?
We understand from this
narration that this man that
the prophet was speaking to, he
didn't have a problem with
whether Islam was true or
false. He knew that it was the
truth. You understand? He knew
that it was correct. That it
was the religion of Allah. He
just found that he didn't like
to do it. So, the prophet
instructed him, do it in spite
of yourself. If you know it's
true, then, do it. Even if you
find that you don't want to,
even if you find that your body
rebels against you, do it
because when you do it, what
will happen is you will lean
into a cycle that will take you
to step by step to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Every time
you do something good it will
soften and open your heart and
the more your heart is soften
and open, you will do more good
and the more good you do, it
will open and soften your heart
more. And the more your heart
is soften and open, the more
good you will do. And you
continue in this cycle. We
understand? So the issue is any
truth. What do we understand?
What is the lesson to be taken
here?
The
Nakuul the
[Silence]
Have we ever heard of the of
the term and acquired taste?
An acquired taste? What does
that mean? What is an acquired
taste? An acquired taste is
when something tastes bad and
you force yourself to expose
you expose yourself to it
enough until until you start to
it. So, you until you
start to delight in it. Still
until you start to enjoy it,
right? This is called an
acquired taste. So, the human
being can rewire himself. To
enjoy something and to it.
The point is not that you want
to get up to pray. The point is
that you know it's right. So,
what do you do? You force
yourself to get up and pray.
And more you do this, the
weaker your nephs becomes in
rebelling against that action
Until you come and you acquire
this taste, you start to love
to do this thing, right? It's
we mentioned. I mean, when
we, when we first started
praying and we started praying
it all the time. Which one of
us was excited to get up at the
best time of of, of, of sleep.
And put cold water all over
your face, and all over your
head. And go and head to the
Masjid. And who who enjoyed
this? Nobody enjoys this.
Right? It's the exact best time
of sleep. It's the exact ,
opposite of what you want to
do. You're nice, you're warm,
you're comfortable, you're
sleeping. Oh, it's time to get
up and pray. But what, but what
happens is you know that you
need to. You know that it's the
truth. So, what do you do? You
force yourself to do it. Right?
And when you force yourself to
do it, you will begin, it will
become easier and easier and
easier until that part of your
has changed. Now, if you don't
do it, you feel bad. Right? So,
this is the process that we're
speaking about. When the
prophet said to that man,
become Muslim. He said, I don't
want to. I feel I don't
want to do it. He said, become
Muslim even if you don't want
to do it. That is across the
board. Never leave off any part
of the prophet even if you only
do it once. If you know of
something that is of the
prophet
never completely leave it off.
If you can't do it 100 percent,
do it fifty percent. If you
can't do it fifty percent, do
it ten percent. Never
completely turn your back on
the prophet and his sunnah.
Never. Right? And the more you
practice this discipline, the
more you will be able to do
this thing. And this is what we
call an acquired taste. It's
something amazing that the
human being has. The ability to
change his natural
inclinations, right? A person
may naturally dislike a
particular food, naturally. But
if you force yourself to expose
if you're exposed to that food
all of the time, there's
nothing else to eat but that
food and so on and so forth,
you will eventually start to
and have a taste and
develop a liking to that
food and that goes for
everything, for any action,
right? So, any part of the
things that we're going to
read, the things that we are
going to read are the causes,
the things that cause your
heart to be open, to the Quran
and sunnah. But the things that
we're gonna read are part of
being open to the Quran in
Sunnah. So, what does that
mean? That means that we force
ourselves to do these things
and if we do things, Allah will
soften our hearts and the more
Allah softens and opens our
hearts, the more we will do
these things and we keep on
this until our path is clear to
paradise. We understand this
concept. This is a very
important concept in the Quran.
Right? and I'll give you an
example of verses and
narrations of this concept
There's a narration on the
authority of in which the
prophet said
yesterday
Allah
value in which a person's hand
is cut off in Islamic law. Does
anybody know?
The
It is one fourth of a dinar.
Okay, one fourth of a gold
coin. Agreed upon with all of
the scholars that an egg is not
war or not worth a fourth of a
gold coin. So, if you have a
gold coin, you're gonna buy
four eggs. No way, right? So, a
person's hand cannot be cut off
legally unless the thing that
he stole is worth more than a
fourth of a dinner. Here's the
question. Why did the prophet
say, may Allah curse the thief,
he steals an egg and gets his
hand cut off. When your hand
will never be cut off in
Islamic law, for stealing an
egg. What's the answer? He's
speaking about the eventuality.
He will steal an egg, then
he'll start to steal two, then
he'll start to steal the
chickens, then he'll start to
steal and and he'll continue on
this path until finally hand is
cut off. For something that is
worth it. Do you understand?
When did his hand really get
cut off? When he stole the
first egg? That's when his hand
really got cut off. You guys
understand? Yes. This is the
meaning of this narration. So
when you start on a path of
evil, that first step you took
is actually what lands you in
hell. You understand and just
good, that first step of
good is what lands you into
paradise. We know the narration
of the man who killed
ninety-nine people, right? And
then he went and he asked about
the most knowledgeable of
people and he was sent to a
person who was not
knowledgeable but someone who
was religious. and he said, I
killed ninety-nine people. Can
I repent? He said, how could
you repent? No, no way. You're
going straight to hell. He
said, well, as long as I'm
going to hell, let's make it a
hundred. Because as humans, we
even numbers, right? So,
he made it a hundred. and then
he asked again about the most
knowledgeable of people and he
was sent to a scholar this
time. What did the scholar say?
He said, what is standing
between you and and repentance?
Repent. No matter how many
people you killed, you still
can repent. He said, go to such
and such a land where the
people there worship Allah and
be amongst them because this
land is an evil land and if you
stay here, you will go back to
your old ways. Many of have
heard this narration before,
correct? Correct What did the
man do? He started on his path
towards that place, right? He
died on the way. Did he do any
good yet? He didn't do any good
yet. All he did was start
walking somewhere or riding or
however it was. All he did was
take the first step. But that
first step would have
eventually led him to what? To
doing good. So Allah
compensated him for that.
Correct? And he compensated him
by allowing the angels of mercy
to take his soul. Even though
he had not committed any good
yet. He had not done anything
good yet. We understand? So
here we have an example of
someone who starts on a path of
evil and ends up getting his
hand cut off and a man who
starts on a path of good and
ends up being in paradise
without having done any good
yet because that first step
enters you into that cycle that
we spoke about. The more good
you do, the more your heart is
open. The more your heart is
open, the more good you do. The
more good you do, the more your
heart is open. And when we say
your heart is open, meaning you
learn more. And your heart is
softer and more accepting. And
the more discipline you become,
the more you do. And the more
you do, the more discipline you
become. And it continues on
until you find your path to
Allah. And the opposite is
true. You spiral into darkness.
Okay? So now we're gonna read
what Ibn wrote based on the
explanation that I've just
given. These are the things
which will soften and open the
heart to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Okay?
He says the first thing that
will open the heart and soften
the heart and open the person's
heart to the Quran in Sunnah is
which we spoke about in the in
depth. He said, and based on
how complete a person's is and
based on how intense a person's
still heed is and how pure it
is, that will dictate how much
a person's heart will be opened
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He says, the next thing for
who?
Subhan Allah
a star
[Silence]
your heart will become open and
embracing of the Quran in
Sunnah. Likewise, if says, also
light is a cause for the heart
to become open and for the
heart to become open to the
Quran in Sunnah. What does that
mean? Physical light? Are we
supposed to sleep in the day
and be awake at night or is it
the opposite?
It's the answer, guys. Come on.
the opposite, correct?
Unless you have some duty that
is Islamically legal guard
duty or something that has to
take place at night you are to
sleep in the day, you are to
sleep in the night, and arise
in the day. Right? The prophet
said, the of my
the blessings of my are found
most in its early risings. The
earlier you wake up, and
experience the day from its
beginning, the more Allah will
place in your day. That's where
the majority of the is. Right?
What is the, what is the
significance, the significance
is that is when the day is most
intense. Right? And that time
of day, will help to open your
heart to the Quran in Sunnah.
Witnessing the break of dawn,
witnessing the rising of the
sun, etcetera. These things
soften the heart. and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded
us to seek refuge in him from
the night. Correct? He said,
I seek refuge in the one who
breaks the dawn. From the evil
of that which he's he has
created. and I seek refuge in
him from the evil of the night
when it shrouds everything.
Right? This is one of the dua
that we make. That we seek
refuge in Allah from from the
night. Because evil things take
place at night. Undercover.
There's not a lot of good going
on during the night time. If
people are out all night and
sleeping all day, do we think
good of them or do we think
that they're on some shadiness?
We view them to be sketchy,
correct? Unless they have
something that they're doing
that is legitimate guard
duty or something that works,
something that is legitimate.
Otherwise, the prophet
disliked and discouraged that a
person
Sleep before and that a person
stay awake after Isha. I know I
just ruined the of a lot of
people, right?
Huh?